salut c'est jimmy et je vous retrouve
pour confiner d'ici et d'ailleurs sur la
première aujourd'hui on part à la
rencontre d'une influence euse que vous
connaissez certainement il s'agit de
petits bouts de soleil en sort comment
elle vit son confinement d'en découvrir
un petit peu plus sur elle salue petit
bout de soleil ça fait plaisir de devoir
est de prendre des nouvelles merci
d'ailleurs d'être là avec nous et nous
faire visiter chez toi on est où
exactement
on va rappeler à ceux qui ne te
connaissent pas les rares qui ne
connaissent pas que tes influences euse
en fait tu crées du contenu pour le web
depuis quelques années telle une des
d'ailleurs de celles qui crée et qui
sont les plus connus venant des antilles
combien de personnes te suivre sur des
réseaux est ce que le fait d'être en
confinement a changé quelque chose dans
ta façon de travailler alors peut-être
pas parce que je sais que tu travailles
souvent mais là où tu es là on te voit
en ce moment dans ta chambre
est-ce que ça a vraiment changé ta façon
de produire du contenu
oui mais que tu le fais déjà de chez toi
ça change pas grand chose finalement
là je suis totalement concentré sur ce
qu'il ya à faire
franchement moi je puis dire tu te
rappelle les débuts quand a démarré au
tout début de tout ça a vanté ses
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
te suivent quand il est dit tiens je
vais faire ma première vidéo
si tu avais déjà dans l'idée d'en faire
quelque chose une activité aussi
professionnels du coup c'était juste par
délire lancé comme ça c'est après
l'école et du coup c'est peut-être pour
mettre en pratique ce que j'avais à
l'époque est petit finalement ça a bien
plu aux pieds continuer droite signé
c'est un pourcentage est en fête avec
les gens et du coup belle ceinture reçu
professionnaliser là dedans et puant
tu t'es lancé dernièrement dans le
cinéma également dans un court métrage
que j'ai eu l'occasion de découvrir
j'étais agréablement surpris c'est à
l'occasion du festival prix de court
et puis tu vois je regarde et puis je
vois petit bout de soleil je me suis dit
mais elle fait aussi du cinéma et
franchement c'était très très bien
comment il s'appelait ce court métrage
dans lequel tu as tu va figurer pour mes
canons et j'ai trouvé que tu avais été
très très convaincante franchement je me
disais je veux voir ça comme un comment
choisir je veux voir comment ils jouent
et franchement j'ai trouvé de très
convaincante est ce que c'est le début
peut-être d'une autre carrière d'actrice
qui sait où dans le cinéma ça te
plairait que sa batterie ya plein de
gens qui essaient mais je sais par an
vers aurait là moi je veux mais pas de
varier j'aime bien comment tu arrives à
trouver cette inspiration quand tu fais
tes vidéos à ça dépend des vidéos il ya
des vidéos je vais travailler un petit
en avant puisque faut pas que je lis
certains points a demandé où donc je
vais l'outil les points les candy et
sinon mais son prix style moi je suis
pas ça j'aime pas pour garer je trouve
que c'est tellement envie c'est d'être
spontané dynamique et puis de
retranscrire le truqueur comme ça que je
bosse pour certaines des vidéos et pour
la plupart des océans campath contre
voie aux antilles après le confinement
bien évidemment tu as prévu quelque
chose pour les grandes vacances de
rentrée oui mais normalement je suis
censé rentrer pour les vacances après on
verra comment la situation évolue mais
j'espère que ça
qu'est ce ça va s'améliorer très vite
parce que là pour le coup
bon si on veut pas rentrer je pense que
ce serait très dur pour les antilles
mekhissi sur la descendre oui mais voilà
pression n'a pas les tendances
confinement chez qu'il ya des gens qui
le vivent très bien et des gens qui le
vivent un petit peu plus mal je te sais
très proche des gens qui te suivent
est-ce que tu reçois des messages de
personnes qui te parlent de leurs
angoisses outre pendant ce confinement
tout à fait normal quand elle de la
situation et ça dépend très bien le
continent
si tu devais dire quelque chose passer
un moment un message à tous les gens qui
nous regardent en ce moment et qui
t'apprécie ce serait quoi
voilà se monnayer nous on rappelle t
réseau comment est-ce qu'on peut te
retrouver tout suivre sur internet
si instagram est susceptible de soleil
sur tik tok c'est petit goût de soleil
et sur twitter sceptiques du soleil
froid on va vérifier
merci beaucoup petit bout de soleil
d'avoir pris le temps de passer un petit
moment avec nous merci encore on pense
que tu produis sur le net c'est très
très bien et puis moi je suis sûr qu'on
ne reverra dans des productions
cinématographiques
on attend ça avec impatience franchement
a très vite merci beaucoup
voilà c'est des cons finis d'ici et
d'ailleurs merci nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite sur la première pour
une nouvelle destination
[Musique]